mit putins überfall auf die ukraine
haben sich die akzente der
internationalen politik dramatisch
verschoben von putin aufgezwungen denken
wir zunehmend nicht mehr in der logik
des friedens sondern eher in der logik
des krieges
was bedeutet das für das praktische
handeln der politisch verantwortlichen
wie lässt sich die logik des krise
krieges durchbrechen und wie verhindern
wir eine fortsetzung der
eskalationsspirale ohne die ukraine im
stich zu lassen mit diesen fragen
begrüße ich sie sehr herzlich bei unter
den linken
[Musik]
und hier am tisch begrüße ich sehr
herzlich den außenpolitischen sprecher
der bundestagsfraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen jürgen trittin herzlich
willkommen man begrüße sehr herzlich
professor sind gemetzel historiker mit
dem schwerpunkt militärgeschichte von
der universität potsdam herzlich
willkommen man sie beide hätten am
wochenende fand der kleine parteitag der
grünen statt und es wurde für die
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
er votiert damit wurde ja der kurs der
ampel oder der regierung letztendlich
auch unterstützt ihr parteichef in ruhe
pur betont gleichzeitig dass die grünen
nach wie vor friedenspartei sind passt
das zusammen ist das nicht in sich den
widerspruch
ich glaube wenn man das erreichen will
dass wir deutschland im rahmen der nato
was die amerikaner erreichen wollen
nämlich dass die ukraine nicht überrannt
werden kann und auf dieser basis dann
eine politische lösung gefunden werden
kann dann ist es notwendig diesen
schritt zu tun und waffen zu liefern das
tun wir nicht weil wir glauben dass es
einen endgültigen militärischen sieg
über russland geben hat
man sich das vor augen führt was sie
gerade definiert haben dann sind aber
letztendlich ja alle parteien im
bundestag auf friedens parteien geht da
nicht den grünen auch ein stück weit
etwas von ihrer historie von ihrem
nimbus von ihrem siedlungen verloren ich
weiß nicht die geschichte der grünen ist
ja auch in sich widersprüchlich wir
haben diese debatten
1999 geführt als wir selber krieg
geführt haben übrigens in einem
völkerrecht nicht nicht ganz so gut
begründeten krieg wie möglich die
abwehrschlacht heute der ukraine gegen
den völkerrechtswidrigen angriff wir
haben aber auch zu den zeiten als sich
hunderttausende auf dem bonner hofgarten
versammelt haben
und aus dieser bewegung heraus hat die
grünen gegründet worden da war auf
diesem hof garten auch menschen
unterwegs die haben für solidarität mit
dem endziel gekämpft das war keine
gewaltfreie bewegung außer nelson
mandela gezwungenermaßen gewaltfrei bei
dem knast gesehen
wir haben waffen später für el salvador
gesammelt das heißt der kampf gegen eine
illegitime
menschenverachtende politik dass sich
wehren hat auch zur dna gehört neben dem
nuklear pazifismus der sich in der
friedensbewegung ausgedrückt
der professor muss man gleich zum anfang
der diskussion schon sagen dass
pazifismus nur was für für
friedenszeiten ist und der pazifismus
letztendlich dann endet sowie gefahr für
leib leben und wird
ja es ist ja die frage welche reichweite
hat der pazifismus also pazifismus haben
wir steht im neunzehnten jahrhundert in
dieser bewegung und hatte ja hat die
kriege des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts das
zeitalter extreme nicht verhindern
können und trittin hat er den bonner
hofgarten erwähnt aber trotzdem gab es
den absolut doppelbeschluss und meines
erachtens auch zu recht ich war damals
einen hessischen gesamtschule und da
waren also mit einer ausnahme auf alle
zahlen gegen die stationierung von
pershing 2 und cruise missile aber
trotzdem hat die bundesregierung dann
einen anderen kurs eingeschlagen und es
ist teil unserer politischen dna das ist
auch gut dass es das gibt und es ist ja
nicht schlimm aber jetzt wenn alle einer
meinung werden wir müssen um das
richtige argument regen ich glaube dass
bestimmten phasen das pazifistische
argument sein gegen waffen eben nicht
selber trägt und der bundeskanzler hat
ja in seiner rede am ersten mal auch
gesagt ich glaube jetzt und diese
stimmen gibt es ja auch bei den kirchen
über den gewerkschaften und der ukraine
einen zivilen widerstands zu empfehlen
gar mit dem hinweis auf den niedergang
der ddr als argument gibt aber ich hatte
das eben für nichts herr weit führen und
die meisten in diesem lande sagen auch
neue attraktive angedeutet hat also
selbstverteidigung sollten wir schon
machen und auch das ist so ein genannt
worden es ist ja eine illusion die linke
und die gewaltfreiheit zusammenzubringen
die linke war nie gewaltfrei und hatte
immer auch dieses element und von daher
es gibt diese stimmen ich halte nur das
für nicht sehr zielführend in diesem
moment es gibt ja die praxis muss gar
nicht verdammen man muss schon sehen
aber es gibt hier sein dürfen und der
pazifisten oder nein unter bestimmten
bedingungen war ein durchaus erfolgreich
wenn sie mal sehen die unabhängigkeit
indiens gegen die kolonialherrschaft
entlang einer parlamentarischen
demokratie
wurde mit diesen methoden erkämpft und
da war der pazifismus anders als andere
versuche zur unabhängigkeit zu kommen
erfolgreich gewesen das hat natürlich
immer zu tun mit rahmenbedingungen wo
ein niedergang eines ehemaligen
weltmacht der fall gewesen ist wo es
auch innerhalb der eigenen
demokratischen gesellschaft viele
stimmen gab die diese form des
kolonialismus nicht mehr wollten und auf
diese weise ist dann da ich sage das nur
der vollständigkeit halber dass man
nicht so tut als wenn pazifismus
historischen platz hat durch den hat er
den
posten hat sie wir wollen uns heute mit
den logischen beschäftigen mit denen mit
den kriegs aber auch den frieden slogan
die es ja durchaus gibt vor allen dingen
der gestalters dass diese logik im jahr
zwangsläufigkeit
nach sich ziehen unterliegt die
konflikte und kriege eskalation festen
dynamiken gibt es da im logischen auch
wenn man in die geschichte zurück blickt
naja es ist eben sehr sehr viele
einflussfaktoren und wir alle sind ja
immer schauen in die geschichte und
suchen uns dann das beispiel raus was
gerade passt dann sie geschichte ist ein
bisschen so ein wühltisch und neuer ich
wusste das war doch schon dauern da so
also die einflussfaktoren sind eben
immens und denken sie mal an den
ausbruch des ersten weltkriegs der
staatliche druck ja immer noch warum er
dann ausgebrochen ist und es gibt dazu
mehr literatur als in ihrem leben lesen
können also es gibt in der tat
fälle die man als historisches beispiel
leben können es gibt bestimmte logik
eskalation slogan die man als als
beispiel heranziehen kann das
fragt uns aber nicht davor in der
jetztzeit unserer eigenen
schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen weil wir
wissen eben nicht welches historische
beispiel genau genau die parallele ist
und keiner von uns kann mangels quellen
putin in den kopf schauen wir wissen
letztlich nicht was da genau besprochen
können wir daraus lernen naja also ja
können wir nur wir können schon also zb
die eskalation slogan nicht ist
sicherlich wichtig irgendwie zu einem
kompromiss zu kommen wir können aus der
geschichte lernen dass man sagt es so
lange das militärische argument gespielt
bis beide seiten eine
kompromissbereitschaft haben ja das sind
sie vorn mal ende aber ich möchte jetzt
erst noch mal am anfang bei der
eskalation selber aber auch da nicht das
ist die frage was kann ich eigentlich
wie erreichen wir werden uns als drucker
die frage stellen haben wir nicht
bestimmte signale putins einfach
wirklich überfahren was immer noch nicht
diesen krieg rechtzeitig davon putin
aber haben wir bestimmte signale nicht
sagen überfahren weil wir alle dachten
also krieg wird das schon nicht führen
also ist das kam mir ein unsere referenz
zu haben nicht vor und damit wird man
sich beschäftigen aber ich glaube schon
dass die aus der geschichte insofern
gelernt haben oder die nato ja
sehr deutlich gemacht hat sie wird sich
nicht in diesem krieg reinziehen lassen
das unterscheidet uns von 114 wir werden
nicht also ich sehe kein szenario wo man
selbst nicht bei dem einsatz von
atomwaffen in der ukraine wo die nato
mit eigenen soldaten kämpfen ich glaube
schon dass die bundesregierung und
europa sagen ja die ukraine soll als
staates überleben aber wir sind nicht
bereit zu kämpfen und das ist auch eine
lehre weil wir jetzt ja auch mit ist ein
zwei atommächte die gegeneinander
letztlich die usa und dann das hatten
wir noch nicht diesen fall in der ja
schon bekommen wir gleich auch noch
näher zu herr trittin also es geht auch
letztendlich am bündnis systeme wir
haben es gerade gehört geht um beistand
verpflichtungen um die nato um die
mitgliedschaft kann man sagen dass es
solche festen bündnisses dem wir dann
auch stabilisierend wirken
in unserem fall wirken sich
stabilisieren wir haben so etwas
entschieden dass wir eine multilaterale
sierung unserer sicherheitsarchitektur
haben so muss auch eine lehre aus den
beiden europäischen weltkriegen gewesen
an dieser stelle
wir hatten ein hohes maß an stabilität
der abschreckung als es zwei blöcke gab
aber ich glaube das ist einer der
grundpfeiler der auch viele unserer
diskussionen hier in deutschland
begleitet hat wir haben immer die
logischen aus dieser alten block
konfrontation mehr oder weniger auf
russland übertragen aber diese alte
sowjetunion das war so eine status quo
macht die war
damit sie ihre frieden dass sie nicht
angegriffen wurde und die hat auch nicht
viel andere angegriffen von einigen
ausnahmen der dritten welt und
stellvertreterkriege mal abgesehen
das was putins herrschaft von anbeginn
an ausgemacht hat war eine
revisionistische ansage also die
niederlage in die unter jelzin
insbesondere aber aus ihrer erzählung
auch unter gorbatschow dieser werte und
nun geraten ist mit dem ende der
sowjetunion zu revidieren und es war
immer von anbeginn an einer herrschaft
die auf dem ausnahmezustand und auf der
logik des krieges beruhte und da schreit
nach eskalation und deswegen waren die
ganzen instrumente
des containments auch wandel durch
annäherung und so eigentlich an dieser
stelle falsch platziert und das haben
wir dann bitter gelernt als europäer wir
haben ja gesagt gedacht mit diesen
harten ökonomischen
sanktionen schrecken wie ihn ab den
krieg anzufangen und jetzt haben wir
diesen worten sogar taten folgen lassen
aber müssen selber feststellen
dass das wohl nicht den ausbruch des
krieges verhindert hatte und ob es ihn
ausbremst das würde eine frage von ganz
langer strategischer geduld werden und
wir können sehen es gibt keines
logisches beispiel wo sanktionen ein
krieg entschieden
wir haben immer auch in dem jugoslawien
krieg und so wie immer auf sanktionen
gesetzt und das war eigentlich so mittel
wir wollen keinen krieg führen und haben
uns selber
glauben gemacht das würde etwas bringen
aus der geschichte hätte man da lernen
können
es gibt keinen fall der mir einfallen
würde das der moderation wirklich sind
konflikt gelöst oder ausgedruckt und
also sanktionen bringen nichts der
trittin sprach gerade davon dass wir
immer noch in der logik des kalten
krieges auch ein stück weit gedacht
haben und damit russland auch falsch
eingeschätzt haben teilen sie diese
ansicht
ja also ich glaube schon ein fehler war
dass wir russland mit der sowjetunion
gleicht das ging ja schon sprachlich zum
teil so dass wir diesen diesem post
imperialen schmerz nicht wirklich
verstanden haben und wir immer glaubten
auch die hoffnung und das ist ja auch
nichts falsches die hand auszustrecken
putin einbinden zu können der wird
vielleicht keine westminster demokratie
aber da muss man doch irgendwie zusammen
kommen und wir haben uns einfach
geweigert zu erkennen dass der krieg
putin faktoren mittel der politik ist
und coaching in georgien und so weiter
nur wir haben das nicht wahrgenommen und
sagen na ja das war irgendwie nicht so
nicht und weil wir dann uns auf diese
logik hätten einstellen müssen dann
hätte man
viel herum viele harte konsequenzen
nachdenken müssen und das wollte
natürlich niemand das war auch insgesamt
in europa nicht die nicht die stimmung
also zumindest nicht in westeuropa und
in ostmitteleuropa vielleicht schon eher
und das ist ja die größte
herausforderung in den außenpolitischen
beziehungen
einen ein wissen über den anderen aus
einer kartoffel sowie denkt der andere
und ich verstehe ich noch nicht mal die
briten mit dem werk richtet nicht und
obwohl wir da unsere kinder hinschicken
und das studiert haben und so wenn wir
die briten noch nicht mehr verstehen wie
verstehen wir dann die russen wir haben
sicherlich auch kein aufschwung sagte
ich mal der osteuropa kompetenz erlebt
nach dem ende des zweiten weltkrieges
und da kann man ja mal überlegen welche
außenpolitiker spricht eigentlich
russisch und so weiter also es gibt
natürlich solche aber das ist uns eine
bundeskanzlerin aber insgesamt verstehen
wir vielleicht dann den westendorf mehr
aber auch dabei den usa
wir ratlos und das ist kein gutes
zeugnis für uns weil wir uns immer aus
der logik des anderen sehen müssen aber
ich meine es ging ja auch allen hoch
bezahlten experten sowieso kaum einer
hat ja wirklich damit gerechnet dass
bückling diesen krieg zu führen würde
hätte putin den krieg auch so geführt
werden die ukraine ukraine tatsächlich
mitglied in der nato gewesen wäre das
glaube ich nicht aber das stand ja gar
nichts von debatten ihr den fall dass
wir nach minsk eine situation hatten wo
man geglaubt hat durch eine vereinbarung
in der beide geben und nehmen mussten
einer befriedung der situation hinzu
kommen und beide seiten
selensky wie putin haben winzer
abgelehnt das muss man deutlich zu sagen
und das was jetzt stattfindet ist das
auskämpfen von putins seite mit zu
revidieren und die ziel der ukraine ist
ist auch rückgängig möglichst zu machen
das muss man sich an dieser stelle klar
machen aber das war eigentlich der kern
und in der tat haben wir nicht geglaubt
dass er das ist und ich bin ja nur und
auf verweisen was wir auch an
unterrichtungen zum teil aus dem
sicherheits establishment bekommen hat
die der bnd die bundeswehr waren
eigentlich der auffassung das kann er
nicht machen damit ich sags mal so und
das paradoxe ist sie hatten auch ein
stück weit recht das was die bundeswehr
erklärt hat in der lage einschätzung vor
dem krieg war dass die ganze logistik
struktur der hat zu schwach wäre um die
ukraine anzugreifen genau daran ist
jetzt dieser vorstoß gescheitert wir
haben nur geglaubt die können ja nicht
so blöd sein mit dieser fehlenden
struktur das zu machen und das war eine
deutliche fehleinschätzung da war die
einschätzung der amerikanischen dienste
die das meer aus der politischen logik
gedacht haben wahrscheinlich zu treffen
und war nicht hatten die amerikaner auch
noch andere informationen als in
deutschen würde ich vermuten das kann
sein wenn wir uns jetzt die eskalation
logik dann auch ein stückweit anschauen
dann stellt sich ja die frage wann
wird die nato oder werden einzelne
staaten die die ukraine unterstützen
letztendlich auch eine kriegspartei
ja also wir haben diese völkerrechtliche
situation die ist ja sagen klar
beantwortet und wir haben die
wahrnehmung ich werde mir das mal wieder
mit dem historischen beispiel nehmen die
amerikaner und entließ wird ja auch
dieser tage zitiert und im märz 41 die
amerikanische unterstützung für die
briten und dann auch für die sowjetunion
die amerikaner waren formell nicht im
krieg de facto wahnsinns natürlich schon
und war entschlossen in diesem krieg
einzutreten auf seite der der freien
welt aber hitler hat die usa nicht als
kriegspartei betrachter dann hat auch
gezögert und hat sagen wollte sie sagen
ja auch aussagen und es hängt also sehr
von den wahrnehmungen ab und das macht
es wieder so schwer einzuschätzen und
was ist jetzt sind jetzt die 50 war die
50 gratis die britischen spezialkräfte
die in der ukraine operieren ist das
jetzt sozusagen die hürde wir können uns
anders als auf das völkerrecht berufen
das hilft aber nicht nachdem putin sagt
sachen jetzt ist es zu viel und jetzt
setze ich ja im schlimmsten fall
taktische nuklearwaffen 1 da kann man
nur hoffen dass die treiber dieser sache
da sind ja die usa in großbritannien und
nicht nicht nicht die bundesrepublik sie
wissen was sie tun und sieht man ja wenn
man denn man kann es dann schon wenn man
kanzler scholz wird dann hat man schon
den eindruck mit der lieferung von
schweren waffen passiert da schon etwas
das man ein stück weit trickst partei
wird oder wie schätze nicht sein also
dass spiegel -interview hielt ich für
unglücklich in den entscheidenden
formulierung weil er hat ja auch wenn es
nicht genau gesagt hat schon die
lieferung von schweren waffen in eine
verbindung zur atomkrieg und dritter
welt geschickt zu verlieren da würde ich
ein bisschen abrüsten denn selbst wenn
die russen und das ist das was bei
experten diskutiert wird das wenn die
russen falls die russen den dom bass
verlieren soll und was sie dann
vielleicht taktischen nuklearwaffen
einsetzen um eine ukrainischen vormarsch
zu stoppen und dann reden wir aber
zunächst von mini nukes die als
demonstration eingesetzt werden und wir
reden nicht vom globalen atomkrieg und
strategischen nuklearwaffen über london
oder washington oder moskau und wir
haben zu sehen eine eine verbale
eskalation
atomwaffen atomkrieg untergang der welt
und also in diesem szenario sehe ich
keinen seriösen experten der so
argumentiert wir müssen immer sagen wir
wissen natürlich nicht was passiert und
dass deswegen fand ich das ein bisschen
unglücklich und ich glaube nicht dass
die lieferung von 40
40 jahre alten schützenpanzer dazu
führen wird dass putin nun seit und das
ist jetzt aber der grund das wird sich
viel stärker an dem aufhängen was die
briten und was die amerikaner amerikaner
machen zumal wir das darüber kann
trittin und anderen nicht offen sprechen
wir viel mehr machen ist nur öffentlich
nicht bekannt ist dass man sich über
putin was die bundesrepublik macht also
da könnte es noch träger lions geben
über die wir gar nicht öffentlich
diskutieren die aber ja
trittin wenn es tatsächlich eine frage
der wahrnehmung ist obmann kriegspartei
ist oder nicht sind wir kriegspartei
meiner auffassung nicht ich kann mich
darauf ein ganz einfaches beispiel
berufen die russen haben ja auch mal
gute kämpfe unterstützt zb den kampf des
heldenhaften volkes von vietnam gegen
die usa da haben wir richtig schweres
gerät geliefert und die übrigens zum
teil war das kriegsentscheidend das
stimmt nicht dass waffenlieferungen iii
nachricht beendet haben da schon
an dieser stelle und selbstverständlich
haben weder die usa noch die russen sich
in dieser situation als kriegspartei
angesehen und ähnlich in korea es ist ja
ein chor so gewesen dass sogar russische
piloten in nordkoreanischen maschinen
flogen aber den yahoo den grenzfluss
nordkorea china nicht überflogen haben
und also da haben schon beide seiten
darauf geachtet sich da entsprechend
raus so wenn ist der rechtliche seite
eindeutig wir aber wissen nicht dass
wird da bin ich ganz bei einem neitzel
von den
geschehnissen am boden abhängen
wird putin seine eklatante schwäche
seiner truppen überwinden oder wird er
in die grenzen gehalten wird ergab
zurückgedrängt wie er dann darauf
reagiert das ist aber weniger nachfrage
der lieferung von schweren waffen als
des kriegs verlauf ist an dieser stelle
was man sagen muss und das ist schon
etwas was mich dann besorgt ich auch
wenn ich die einschätzung teilen dass
wir hier über
taktische und kleinere atomwaffen reden
für den fall einer solchen eskalation
die frage ob ein atomkrieg tatsächlich
für bar ist und ähnliches das ist eine
ganz neue frage in der praxis und
deswegen ist auch die angst die ja viele
menschen in der bevölkerung umtreibt vor
allem neuen atomkrieg die ist nicht
rational sondern die wahrscheinlichkeit
einer nuklearen
auseinandersetzung aufgrund der
aggression putins deutlich höher
geworden wenn es vom 24
fünf vor zwölf für den atomkrieg an dann
sind wir jetzt zwei vor 12 wobei ich
sagen muss ich glaube nicht die frage
dass man durch spielen wenn putin
wirklich ein oder zwei taktische
nuklearwaffen zünden würde dann wäre das
nach meinung der experten eine macht
also ein warnsignal an kiew was wir im
kalten krieg durchgespielt haben den
einsatz von hunderten taktischen
nuklearwaffen um einen auf dem
gefechtsfeld zu siegen aber bleibt es
dabei ein warnsignal gegen kiew das ist
relativ vage werden hingegen leben
darauf reagiert und ich glaube dass
spätestens dann auch die nato-staaten
seien wurden also wir sollten
die sache mal runter verhandeln ich
glaube auch nicht dass die usa irgendein
interesse daran hat die sache zu sagen
irgendwie zu eskalieren und es gibt ja
auch experten die selbstzweifel ziehen
wenn putin sagen aber wenn baltikum
nuklearwaffen einsetzen wird ob dass die
usa überhaupt sehen würden um zu
antworten und ich glaube schon meine
wahrnehmung der usa ist jetzt dass sie
zwar das konventionell unterstützen aber
dass keiner ein interesse an dem einsatz
dieser waffen also das muss man
natürlich mit bedenken am krieg soll
auch da bin ich wieder bei hinziehen wir
können schon szenarien aufstellen und
dafür wird ja auch gewarnt wenn putin
alles verlieren sollte muss man dieser
logik er ist eben nico stoff erst nicht
recht
ersten ergebnissen für ihn um alles aber
mein eindruck aus in meinem besuch in
den usa ist auch ganz eindeutig die
waren zum beispiel was das liefern von
richtigen kampfpanzern also angeht
mindestens so zurückhaltend wie die
bundesregierung weil man eben genau
dieses reinziehen in die nukleare
auseinandersetzung nicht will da ist
beiden sehr klar gewesen und wenn ich
die äußerungen von herrn tony blinken
vom senat richtig interpretiere ist auch
da die ansage wir liefern um zu einer
verhandlungslösung sondern es ist eine
alte
arrangierte haltung der us
administration die aus diesen modernen
konflikten raus resultiert barack obama
hat mal gesagt die enden nicht mit sieg
oder neelie kroes nur vanquish
das ist so die schule in den usa die
zurzeit in dieser administration und wir
können uns glücklich schätzen dass wir
diese administration haben die dinge
bestimmt aber
reicht diese denke aus wenn man den
ukrainischen botschafter vom wochenende
hört der sagt wir werden bereits mitten
in einem dritten weltkrieg
ist das ist das etwas was zu dieser
kriegslogik und dann auch zu dieser
kommunikations you logik in dieser in
dieser situation dazu gehört
es ist public diplomacy ob sie glücklich
ist muss die ukraine entscheiden da muss
man glaube ich also aus die ukraine
kommuniziert anders das kann man auch
ein stück weit nachvollziehen die
kollegen ist daran interessiert den
westen möglichst umfassend in diesem
konflikt hineinzuziehen auch die
forderung nach flugverbotszone das ist
aus ukrainischer sicht ja
nachvollziehbar und die ukraine hat
interessen wer aber auch interessen und
diese interessen haben einen aber sie
sind nicht identisch
herzl der der kanzler warnt ja auch so
ein stück weit vor der hochgerüstete
supermacht russlands wir haben es eben
schon so ein bisschen anklingen lassen
den drohenden atomkrieg kann man mit
dieser kriegslogik die man sonst
vielleicht hatte überhaupt putin
entgegentreten wird da nicht etwas
ausgehebelt was wir sonst in unserem
denkmal hatten dass da ein rote linie
ist die keiner überschreiten will
also ich glaube es herrscht krieg in der
ukraine und wir müssen uns diesem krieg
stellen und damit auch der logik des
krieges wir können nicht jetzt die
friedenstaube fliegen lassen und mit
john gummibällen antworten sondern wir
das ist sagen notgedrungen uns hier
aufgezogen worden die bundesrepublik ist
nun wirklich mit versuchen der
diplomatie nun wirklich bis zum
äußersten gegangen und man kann ihm
nicht vorwerfen sie hätte das nicht
versetzung das hat nicht zum erfolg
geführt und jetzt sind wir nummer in dem
krieg und hoffentlich endet er bald aber
jetzt müssen wir und die logik ist jetzt
ja das meines erachtens das sagen auch
fast alle experten
putin muss an den punkt kommen wo er
einsieht ich komme mit militärischen
mittel nicht weiter aus verschiedenen
gründen mit dem moor ein problem der
logistik problemen und ich komme nicht
weiter und das einzige was mir bleibt
ist eine verhandlung so und dann muss
der westen sicherlich auch druck ausüben
auf die ukraine und dann wird man sehen
was da rauskommt solange putin glaubt
mit dem militärischen mitteln den gegner
seinen willen aufzwingen zu können wie
klaus als das gesagt hat wird er das tun
und da hilft eben nur auch kein ziviler
widerstand oder dergleichen sondern die
ukraine muss es schaffen
die die russische aggression zu stoppen
und dann ist hoffentlich trittin als
angedeutet ist hoffentlich der weg frei
und da haben die amerikaner die
entscheidende rolle nicht die
bundesrepublik das mandant einer garten
verhandlungslösung kommen von der wir
jetzt ja noch gar nicht sehen wie die
aussehen kann weil es ist klar was die
ukraine wollen und klaus die russen und
da haben wir noch ein relativ großes
delta dazwischen aber wir müssen in
dieser logik sein und deswegen begrüße
ich auch sehr die rede vom 27 februar
wir haben uns nicht für die bundeswehr
nicht für die militärische logik
interessiert wir haben die bundeswehr
von vielen gedacht und darf man ja die
ist für kohle und ich weiß nicht was als
social worker ist die gut jetzt merkt
man kaum leben kann man vielleicht auch
für andere dinge verwenden es gar nicht
schlecht wenn man die hat also keiner
wie sie leben nicht in einem in einer
kicker kultur in einem staat der ja
sagen dass militärische nach vorne
schieben wird aber ganz ohne geht es mal
gesagt uns auch nicht und das ist ein
stück weit wenn wir uns die dänemark
ansehen niederlande italien das sind
alles keine krieger stand aber die alle
gehen davon aus dass die militär zur
anderen anwendung militärischer gewalt
hass wenn wir das war verstehen würden
hätten wir schon ein riesenschritt nach
vorne gemacht
wenn wir uns die unberechenbarkeit von
putin serien davon vorhin ja schon
gesprochen doch mal ein stück weit
anschauen und der professional sich ja
auch schon so ein bisschen von von
möglichen verhandlungslösungen oder oder
szenarien spricht wie man sich
vielleicht dann doch verhandlungs
technisch annähern kann
kann man sich das überhaupt vorstellen
dass putin sich tatsächlich irgendwann
an einen verhandlungstisch seit
ich habe immer die was man sich alles
nicht vorstellen kann da muss man schon
sehr vorsichtig sein wenn sie vor 15
jahren gefragt hatten kann man sich
vorstellen dass die nato sich an einen
tisch mit den taliban setzt unmöglich
das waren verbrecher
fünf jahre später haben die deutschen
ein büro für die taliban in doha
angemietet jetzt von den amerikanern
bezahlt wird so insofern ist diese frage
ja es wird zu genau diesen verhandlungen
kommen und die frage die sich für uns
stellt ist eigentlich eine die darüber
hinaus weist wir haben uns angewöhnt von
sanktionen zu sprechen ich bin da sehr
zurückhaltend das was wir gerade machen
sind keine sanktionen wir koppeln
russland zumindest vom zugang von den
europäischen und den g7 märkten ums
präziser zu sagen letztendlich
wirtschaftlich ab und das wird nicht
morgen früh mit der einfachen
versicherung jetzt ist waffenstillstand
und da bleiben wir auch erst mal bei
rückgängig gemacht werden sondern das
wird man nur zurück bauen können wenn
wir wieder zu einer belastbaren
europäischen friedensordnung kommen also
im grunde genommen so etwas wie wir
1985 mal mit bösen brechen jetzt aber
putin würde auch sagen ganz verdächtiger
mann stammte aus der ukraine mit mit
brechen hat den der wm europa und die
nato diese vereinbarung über die
unantastbarkeit der grenzen geschlossen
und das auch hinterlegt und wir würden
erst in einem solchen zustand wieder auf
diese frage zurückkehren das ist
eigentlich die große herausforderung
aber wichtig man muss so schnell es geht
dazu kommen zumindest diesen temporären
waffenstillstand zu haben gehört es zur
kriegslogik auch ein stück weit dazu
dass es ein militärisches ergebnis
letztendlich geben wird und
können sie wenn wir uns jetzt die zeit
des krieges anschauen bei putin
unterschiedliche ziele
seines krieges sehen im vergleich zu dem
was er vielleicht einmal anfangen
kommuniziert hat also ich glaube das
kriegen können wir eben nicht als black
box denken und sagen wie beginnen sie
wie enden sie wir müssen sie eben auch
also das entscheidende wie kriege eben
enden ist eben auch wie werden sie
geführt so zu sagen was passiert auf dem
schlachtfeld wir neigen dazu ja auch
nicht zuletzt in der wissenschaft das
herauszunehmen und wir sehen ja dass das
schlachtfeld im engeren sinne auch
entscheidend ist die keiner von uns
gedacht dass die ukraine soweit kämpfen
können moral ausrüstungen taktik was ich
so also und das sind in ganz engeren
sinne eben militärische fragen die hier
von eminenter bedeutung sind und wir
sehen ja dass die
die erste phase eben waren 96 stunden
diese regierung im wirklichen einer
spezialoperation auszuschalten und
offenbar kann russland ja relativ nah
dran sie lenski aussagen zu fangen zu
töten das ist alles gescheitert dann gab
es eine zweite phase umgruppiert hat das
dann auch nicht geklappt das haben wir
eine dritte phase und das ist für uns
also zumindest für mich der jetzt nicht
die bnd briefings liest aber doch mit
übereinander spricht schwer wirklich da
in diesem militärischen details
anzusehen weil gerade die ukraine und
aus meiner erfahrung relativ wenig sagen
was jetzt wirklich bei ihnen passiert
wir wissen zum teil mehr über die russen
als über die ukraine aber es wird ein
militärisches ergebnis gehen so oder so
auch wenn wir da nicht die größten
details kenne es wird ein militärisches
ergebnis geben und danach wird agiert
und das militärische ergebnisse muss aus
unserer sicht sein dass putin sagt
militärisches game over so geht es nicht
habe ich mir anders vorgestellt und dass
er dann hoffentlich sagt wir verhandeln
und die große gefahr ist so gibt's ja
auch einige analysen sie sagen er wird
in einigen wochen einen einseitigen
waffenstillstand verkünden und sagen so
ich habe eigentlich schon mal etwas
erobert und es reicht mir und der westen
steht erstmal pudert da und es wird
keine verhandlungen geben sondern er
versucht kraft zu schöpfen für eine
weitere runde die parallelen die wir
haben russisch sowjetischer winterkrieg
39 40 liefen ja so in mehreren wellen
oder auch der dom bass 14 und man kann
nur hoffen dass auch der schock das
nicht erfolgen so groß ist dass er sagt
naja also mit militärischen mitteln geht
es nicht weiter weil der westen jetzt
kommen die waffenlieferungen so richtig
bei derwesten sagt wir werden die
ukraine immer so stark halten dass du
mit konventionellen militärischen mittel
nicht weiterkommt das ist unsere message
und dann in der hoffnung dass dort
verboten sagt ich werde den
rüstungswettlauf mit dem westen nicht
gewinnen
hätte ihn wenn wir uns das anschauen
dass es ein militärisches ergebnis recht
geben muss in irgendeiner form kann das
dann so aussehen dass es tatsächlich zu
einer gespaltenen ukraine kommt und wenn
wir professor nein zu hören dass er sagt
irgendwann wird putin vielleicht einfach
einen waffenstillstand verkünden kann
dass vielleicht sogar der neunte bei
dieser sehr symbolträchtigen tag für
russland sein ja kann man drüber
spekulieren ich glaube aber dass die
letzten tage gezeigt haben dass das was
sie sich für den 9 mai vorgenommen haben
sie bisher nicht umsetzen konnten das
ist richtig so die idee war ja im raum
dass sie zumindest die ob last grenzen
von dom esch und land erreichen davon
sind sie entfernt und das was ich
fürchte ist das nimmt dann ja auch
aufmerksamkeit ein stück weg dass wir in
so eine situation kommen eines einseitig
verhängen waffenstillstands dann sind
alle erst mal froh zu rechte stirbt
niemand mehr aber dass wir nicht
verstehen dass dies kein eingefrorener
konflikt ist bezweifeln inzwischen nach
den erfahrungen die wir in georgien und
selbst in moldau haben dass es so etwas
wie eingefrorene konflikte gibt sondern
dass da immer einer der die eskalation
hat hat es in der chance hat die wieder
anzuwärmen zu erhitzen an dieser stelle
was heißt das denn für mögliche
verhandlungen des darms haben war ich
wieder meine dieser politik dass die
ukraine so ausgestattet wird dass sie
nicht überrannt wird auch dann festhält
wenn man nicht mehr in unmittelbaren
kampfhandlungen ist und nicht
unmittelbar an dieser stelle jeden tag
in den medien sieht was dort an
entmenschlicht daher muss sagen
kriegsverbrecher kriegsführung
stattfindet
wir dürfen dann mit der aufmerksamkeit
nicht plötzlich wo ganz woanders
hingehen an dieser stelle sondern diese
grundhaltung das sage ich sowohl
hinsichtlich der ökonomischen
zwangsmaßnahmen gegenüber russland als
auch gegenüber den lieferungen von
rüstungsgütern das ist etwas wo wir die
ukraine so ertüchtigen müssen dass nicht
ein beliebiger zeitpunkt stattfindet
wieder erneut zu eskalieren
ich glaube von der frage ob und
inwieweit sie in ihrer frage angedeutet
haben die ukraine geteilt wird und
welche teile und ähnliche dinge das ist
jetzt alles viel zu frühe spekulation
ich fürchte er ein solches szenario der
einseitigen waffenstillstandes und dann
ist deutschland sind die amerikaner die
briten alle in der verantwortung in der
unterstützung der ukraine nicht
nachzulassen damit nicht nach belieben
der krieg wieder angefangen werden kann
ist das szenario
das ist ich glaube dass in dem moment wo
putin sagte es ist waffenstillstandes
machen wir frieden und es wird nicht
mehr gestorben doch der drang in
deutschland nach normalität
wer also wechsel stärker werde mich
nicht nur in deutschland nicht nur in
deutschland ist verständlich und da das
argument kommen wird also jetzt ist oft
so zu größeren gebiet verlusten für die
ukraine kommen ja weil aber ich weiß
nicht eben weiter man von europäischen
weg grenze weg geht ist das vielleicht
nicht mehr so relevant und
dann ist die frage ob man nicht sagen na
ja gott es gibt ja den staaten noch und
sie müssen sich damit abfinden und so
also ich glaube schon dass aber da sind
wir doch wieder eine bockwurst zu einer
annexion kommt ähnlich wie bei der krim
und wie dann bitten zurück deutschland
zu offen und haben ja und wieder ein
stück sind ja das ist ja genau die grand
veränderung der die ukraine will
natürlich und die krim haben sie ja
glaube ich rausgenommen letztlich auch
die beiden volksrepublik auch ziemlich
offiziell zurückerobern und sagen keine
russischen truppen auf unserem
territorium aus meiner sicht ist das
illusionäre
aus meiner sicht wäre eine
kompromisslinie die man die vielleicht
noch realistisch wäre wenn die band
volksrepublik russisch wenn man das
akzeptiert aber man zumindest den
landkorridor zurückbekommen wenn man den
land wenn die russen den landkorridor
nicht orden halte ich die ukraine
eigentlich für verstümmelt und
sie brauchen zugang zum meer und das
sind auch wirtschaftlich wichtige
gebiete also das kann man aus kiew sich
glaube ich schwerlich akzeptieren wenn
man nicht unmittelbar vor einer
militärischen niederlage steht und da
ist man eben noch auseinander und aber
der wunsch nach frieden ist das
selbstverständlich in unser aller
gesellschaften ich glaube das ist dieser
ton eben auch in deutschland oder im
rahmen der spd besonders stark werden
würde und da würde ich absolut das
unterstützen was der trittin sagt wir
müssen all den bereichen weitermacht und
übrigens auch in der zeitenwende mit der
bundeswehr und es gibt ja auch schon
stimmen die sagen naja weißrussland ist
doch schon jetzt gegen russland
eingestellt ist aber keine bedrohung des
baltikums mehr also ich bin mir da nicht
so sicher nicht und wir sehen ja wozu
putin bereit ist und wir müssen wir
standen ja eigentlich schon 214 aber
auch jetzt ein stück mit
heruntergelassenen hosen da und das darf
uns nicht wieder dass man zuerst
anschauen was ja professor mentzel
darauf skizziert dass wir gegebenenfalls
einen kompromiss
linie oder eine kompromisslösung finden
müssen die vielleicht da heißt das eben
die gebiete und johanns nicht mehr zur
ihnen letztendlich gehören ist das nicht
eine krachende niederlage des
völkerrechts letztendlich noch mal ich
glaube nicht dass hier solche
vereinbarungen zur zeit zur debatte den
erstens wird niemand das über die
ukraine hinweg regeln zum zweiten haben
wir ja eh ein szenario diskutiert wo die
eine krieg seite sagt wir hören jetzt
auf und die andere dann sich überlegen
kann was sie an dieser stelle machen
kann das ist ja weit davon entfernt
irgendetwas zu völkerrechtlich zu
legitimieren dabei bleibt der
völkerrecht bruch ja offensichtlich ohne
dass geschossen wird ich hab das eben
dazwischen gerufen nicht nur die
deutschen weil ich glaube wir können ja
in einem punkt ganz froh sein als
europäer putins agieren hat den po
virtuell ja der usa ein stück weit
gebremst aber in wirklichkeit wenn man
im kongress im state department
sowie den unsicherheiten gibt es eine
große herausforderung für die usa und
das ist die realität mit china von der
sie der gerade zeit abgehalten werden im
gegenteil der konflikt mit china mindert
sich ein bisschen war china nicht ganz
so unverbrüchlich treu mit russland
agiert wie es das auf konferenzen
versprochen hat aus ganz eigenem
interesse und deswegen sehe ich die
notwendigkeit dass wir sagen müssen ja
wir werden die ukraine auch im falle
eines waffenstillstandes
politisch ökonomischen aber militärisch
weiter unterstützen müssen damit nicht
nach belieben der krieg wieder anfängt
und das wäre ja eigentlich wieder
anfängt aber so wäre eine zeitenwende
wenn deutschland sie auch da an eine
starke stellung gehen würde wenn man es
also nicht hinten rein sondern sagt das
ist eine aufgabe die deutschland auch
wenn die amerikanische aufmerksamkeit
ein wenig nachlässt die deutschland sich
auf die agenda schritt
verstärkt die europäer folge es wird die
europäer fordern und man muss uns vorne
weg
wie fern muss man denn auch
berücksichtigen dass die chinesen sich
das ganz genau anschauen und gucken
inwiefern das dann auch eintritte für
weiteres handeln ist ich glaube das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt in dieser
ansprechen ich glaube dass der westen
was immer das sein soll europa die
nordstaaten sehr genau beobachtet werden
und deswegen wir auch
ein signal der stärke sind müssen was
tun wir jetzt ja auch denn mit den
sanktionen mit der geschlossenheit mit
den waffenlieferungen selbst deutschland
und dass wir geschlossen agieren denn
wenn wir letztlich diese aggression
akzeptiert hätten und zur tagesordnung
übergegangen werden denn da wäre das
eine einladungskarte verschiedener
gewesen es hängt eben internationalen
beziehung unglaublich viel von
konzeptionen von wahrnehmungen und
die wahrnehmung die wir als deutschland
abgegeben haben ist in der
sicherheitspolitik jetzt vielleicht
nicht die des allerstärksten akteurs
nicht und die waren eigentlich immer der
modernisierer der von der außenlinie
also starke worte fand und wenn es dann
darum ging zu agieren stichwort
flugverbotszone in syrien waren wir
erstmal sowieso raus und haben
eigentlich europa da ein stück weit eher
gespalten und das ist jetzt ja
im wesentlichen nicht so sag ich jetzt
mal positiv und das ist ein starkes
signal an china wir können wenn wir die
regelbasierte ordnung verteidigen wollen
können wir das nicht zulassen und da
muss und dann muss man im notfall eben
auch mit mitteln mit denen mit dem tool
mit des militärs agieren was wir so
lange ausgeschlossen haben ich und wir
haben ein stück weit eben den kopf in
den sand gesteckt und das konnten wir
uns erlauben weil andere in unserem
namen agiert haben und ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir daran als
bundesrepublik
stärker agieren und ich bin da sehr
erfreut über die die stimmen die man von
den grünen hört und
ja nicht überrascht von den stimmen die
man zum teil von der spd wird und ich
hoffe dass wir in diese rolle an dem man
denke doch mal an die rolle die
deutschland in der finanzkrise eurokrise
spielt einen finanzminister der doch
wirklich das kann man bei werten wie man
will aber eine starke rolle spielte
germany made the weather das würde man
jetzt in sicherheit hinsichtlich und
nicht unbedingt wieder haben würde ich
sagen haben wir noch ein bisschen luft
nach oben dass die kleinen mittleren
staaten erwarten dass auch wie wichtig
ist denn das zeichen der stärke dass man
jetzt auch abgeben muss gerade im
hinblick auf china auch die frage noch
mal ansehen ich glaube dass china wie
putin auch überrascht ist über die
geschlossenheit mit der die staaten des
demokratischen kapitalismus völlig sie
man n
reagiert haben das war weder auf putins
rechnung noch auf der rechnung chinas
das ist der grund warum sie alle
versuche das die stadt trifft ihre
eigene zahlungsplattform zur verfügung
stellen das alles schön unterlassen
haben wird kommt ein weiteres für china
hinzu sie waren in den letzten jahren
stolz darauf dass sie die korona
pandemie blenden gemanagt haben und der
und jetzt sind sie nicht in der lage die
verwöhntesten teilen der bevölkerung
nämlich in shanghai ordentlich im
lockdown zu versorgen das heißt sie
kriegen auf der einen seite massive
wirtschaftliche probleme sie sind
konfrontiert mit einem überraschend
geschlossen agierenden
staatenverbund im rahmen der g7 und sie
haben zu hause probleme die bis hin zu
offenen protesten und dem muss gehen
deswegen glaube ich dass china
ein stück sich zurücknehmen wird weil
ihre macht projektion war immer in
erster linie ökonomisch und wenn dieser
krieg weitergeht dann ist das auch und
gerade für die eigenen wachstumsziele
für die eigene legitimation die anders
als in russland vor allem auf wohlstand
für alle beruhten richtig eine
herausforderung sind quasi am ende der
sendung heinzl deswegen ausschuss frage
an sie welchen preis sind wir bereit für
die freiheit zu zahlen oder welchem
preis müssen wir auch bereit sein für
die freiheit zu zahlen also
es wäre ja schon schön wenn wir am ende
dieses krieges und wie immer ist
aufwendig gut ausgeht unser klar ist wir
müssen einen preis bezahlen keiner von
uns will kriegt keiner von uns braucht
diesen schlimmen krieg aber wir leben in
einer liberalen demokratie die mir
gefällt diese ordnung gefällt mir gut
und wir müssen dafür für die
verteidigung dieser liberalen
weltordnung einen preis bezahlen und es
geht auch um die revisionsrecht und wir
haben in der geschichte genug beispiele
wie revisionsrecht solche liberalen
demokratischen ordnung in frage stellen
und da können wir nicht nur mit
friedensgebeten angehen und deswegen
müssen wir im äußersten notfall eben
dann auch zu waffenlieferungen oder gar
wenn es anders als territorium geht eben
auch zu militärischen mitteln greifen
und die worte das kannst du das wir
werden jeden quadratmeter nato bodens
verteidigen die worte von einer werbung
einer der bereitschaft das ist alles
musik in meinen ohren ich bin für diese
sachen solche forderungen noch vor
jahren beschimpft worden aber das ist
eine neue realität und ich glaube das
ist ein realismus und ich fürchte nicht
dass wir in einem militärisch muss
abgleiten ich sehe eine besonnenheit in
dieser republik auch in der der
agierenden und ich sehe uns da auf einem
guten weg aber es muss bader zeitenwende
zum schluss was rausgekommen mehr als
warme worte und das müssen wir dann
prüfen anderen mit mit der bitte um eine
kurze antwort herr trittin als die
bundesregierung
begann und annalena baerbock oder die
grünen dann auch von der werte basierten
außenpolitik sprachen und diese dann
auch umsetzen hätten sie auch nur im
entferntesten gedacht dass es so schnell
auch dann tatsächlich zu solchen
handlungen führen wo sind ja gerade in
einer situation wo wir werte und
interessen übrigens in einer weise
verteidigen müssen die wir uns nicht
ausgesucht haben aber auf diese
herausforderung geben wir eine antwort
und ich glaube dass wir sie mit augenmaß
und abgewogen heiten unter benennung
auch der widersprüche die man dabei hat
und ich glaube das ist das wichtige und
das ist auch das was die menschen im
lande brauchen die sich sorgen machen
sie wollen eine regierung die handelt
aber die die kriterien nach denen sie
entscheidet auch deutlich
ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich für diese
durchaus tief greifende diskussionen und
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen sehr herzlich
fürs zuschauen morgen um 22.15 sehen sie
an dieser stelle die phoenix runde und
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend
[Musik]